everybody wants to know the key to
success how do I become successful but
in 1977 when Muhammad Ali was being
interviewed by Phil Donahue Phil asked
him a question and says listen what is
the central part of your training is it
running is it training what is it and
Ali's answer shocked the entire audience
it was funny it was comical but he was
telling 100 truth and by the way if you
give value out of today's video and I
give you the message give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel let me get
right into it so at least being asked
this question what is the central part
of your training and this is what Ali
says to Phil Donahue he says it's
dodging the nightclubs and the parties
and the girls you want the truth and
being in bed by yourself at nine o'clock
at night and if you can get by that
you'll make it
says and that's the truth now I'll tell
you the truth hitting the bags and
jogging and vitamins won't dodging
ladies is the main thing especially when
you're pretty like me so rather than
answering the question of what to do he
told you what not to do right I'm 24 25
years old I got Big Dreams but I love
playing poker when I would finish my
last appointment at 10 o'clock at night
Tuesday night I would go straight to
Commerce at a 45 minute drive I'd go to
Commerce I would play cards for three to
four hours and then I would come back by
five o'clock in the morning I'd get
three hours of sleep then I would go run
my appointments on Wednesday morning
getting three to four hours of sleep so
how effective you think I was on
Wednesday you think I had maybe a little
bit of a shorter fuse you think I could
give my best to close or sell or explain
my clients or build relationship but you
think it was just kind of like hey let
me just kind of give you what I want to
give you that was one of my distractions
the distractions prior to that was going
to the nightclubs the distractions prior
to that was women as much as I was
looking for the keys to success success
sometimes it was about what not to do
not going to the club not going to the
casino to play Blackjack not going and
hanging out with your friends till four
in the morning not doing any of that
stuff that was constant distraction from
doing something big so often rather than
looking for your to-do list sometimes
it's better to make a do not list what
not to do here's what I'm not doing I
told my friends I'm not going to the
club I'm not going to the pool hall I'm
not going to the bar I'm not going to
Vegas I'm not going to go hang out with
another girlfriend of mine I'm not going
to do any of this stuff that gets in my
way instead I'm going to take that time
and develop myself and all of a sudden
you're going to wake up one day saying
how the hell am I competing with
everybody that's best in my industry
it's because of what you didn't do not
necessarily what you did do so if you
got value out of this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel I
got another video I want you to watch I
gave a message seven months ago and the
title of the message keynote was Will
versus want if you've never seen this
video click here to watch that video
take care everybody bye
foreign